كيف كان الحال بالنسبة لك عندما كنت
في حلب ، هل تتذكر أنه كان من
الصعب حقًا أن يموت الكثير من الناس والأطفال ،
فقد بعض أطفالهم
والديهم ، آمل أن نوقفه
ونعيش جميعًا في سلام ماذا تريد
الناس  لنتذكر من كتابك عندما
قرأوه ، لقد كتبت كتابي عن حياتي
وحياة الأطفال أيضًا ، لذا
مثل الكثير من الناس يمكنهم معرفة قصتي
والأطفال الذين يعانون
كل يوم ومثلما تريدهم أن يعرفوا
كيف تبدو  نعم وكيف يصعب
العيش والحرب وكيف يكون الأمر صعبًا
لأنه لا يوجد ماء أو طعام
ودائمًا ما يتم غمغمة القصف ،
لا يمكنك النوم
أحيانًا في منزلك ،
وأحيانًا يتأذى الناس لا يوجد
دواء.  المستشفيات ،
أنت الآن تعيش في
تركيا بالخارج وعليك القدوم إلى أمريكا
لحضور حفل توزيع جوائز الأوسكار إذا كان بإمكانك قول
شيء واحد للقادة الدوليين
وكنت تقول الكثير من الأشياء الصحيحة
التي قلتها كثيرًا بمرور الوقت ولكن
إذا كنت ج  أود أن أقول شيئًا واحدًا لجميع القادة
الذين قد يشاهدون هذه
المحادثة وهو أننا نجري
ما تقوله لهم
إنك تشاهد فقط الأطفال يموتون ،
يجب أن نقف جميعًا معًا وآمل
أن نتمكن من مساعدة الأطفال في جميع أنحاء العالم حتى
الأطفال  يمكن أن نعيش في هذا ويجب أن
نكون أقوياء لمساعدتهم حتى نتمكن من العيش في
هذا ونكون جميعًا سعداء